I'm all justice and yes I did a horrible
mother
you may have already heard about the
Anaheim police shootings in protests
Anaheim police firing rubber bullets
confront a crowd of terrified children
parents and angry residents near La
Palma and Picasso they were sparked by
the shooting death of an unarmed 25 year
old Manuel Diaz was shot and killed on
Saturday as he ran from police in the
city of Anaheim the protests and police
response became violent at one point
1000 people were out here in the street
riding and eventually started smashing
windows at nearby businesses then one
officer unleashes a snarling police dog
which attacks a mother holding her child
this bystander Anaheim mayor Tom Tate
called a special City Council meeting at
the local high school August 8 2012 to
let the public comment on what happened
residents voiced frustration with how
the police handled protesters some came
to support the police we compromised
police officers to defend against
domination
tension built throughout the afternoon
culminating in this moment between
Manuel Diaz's mother and a police
supporter the Los Angeles Times reported
the same day that in 2012 the Anaheim PD
fired its 7 people with their guns
killing 5 that's up from two fatal
shootings in 2011 and none in 2010 the
LA Times says that police blame violent
gangs and it's true that crime in
Anaheim is increasing but when images
like these become the perception of your
Police Department your problem goes
beyond numbers for reason TV i'm paul
dietrich